well we've got uh someone very special
in the studio this morning there is a
new character on the simpsons and
helping raise awareness for breast
cancer survivors and joining us this
morning in the studio is the voice of dr
wendy sage
actress and breast cancer survivor
herself renee ridgely renee it's great
to have you this morning thank you thank
you so much we're just talking about
your character uh and this is really
groundbreaking uh the simpsons has been
on for decades now and tell us about the
character dr sage how did the character
come about
well as a survivor when you go into
advocacy you kind of try to find your
voice there like what you can do so i've
written an episode of the simpsons my
husband is one of the executive
producers on the show and i've done some
voices and i thought wouldn't it be
great if we put a breast cancer survivor
who has chosen what half of the women
who have mastectomy choose which is to
go flat
so
we she's one breasted and she's visibly
one-breasted and there's nothing in the
episode about cancer it's just she's
normalizing flat okay all right and you
have tell us about your personal
experience about this because you're you
are a breast cancer survivor you tried
implants did you not they didn't work
for you no they didn't i had implants
for two years i had revision i had a lot
of problems with um my my muscle i've
kind of lost rotation in this arm and a
lot of pain and then i got sick from my
implants so i had them removed and um i
have to say like being flat i've really
embraced it it's a wonderful community i
feel i feel whole i feel that um this is
the pat the right path for me and and so
many women are doing that now there's
you know there's a lot of um it's a it's
a process with reconstruction so some
women are opting not to do that process
it sounds like very involved i've had
some friends that have gone through it
themselves and tell me about what does
it mean to you to be the voice of a
character like this on a show
that's seen around the world by millions
of people what what does it mean for the
viewing audience
well i'd like to kind of
something that's really profound to me
is that my husband's been working on the
show for so long and
after the episode aired someone a
patient a breast cancer survivor direct
messaged him on twitter and said i'm in
my hospital room and i'm crying because
i just i see myself on tv i just had a
mastectomy and i'm seeing me and i'm
seeing survivorship and so i feel like
i've you know i'm not dr wendy sage i
think she's all of us we kind of have
this hashtag i am sage
and she represents people who um
are have moved on from their treatment
and they're living kind of in their
altered body and accepting that
embracing it and part of the body
positivity movement
does this uh role have a finite role on
the show this character or is it going
to go on and on as far as you know you
know she's already in two or three
episodes this year she's a springfield
resident and will be popping up but she
was on the weekend was on the simpsons a
couple weeks ago an episode that he
wrote and she was standing in line
waiting for shoes at his shoe store so
she's just around town in the way that
we are as survivors and being seen um
you know invisibly different but we're
still here we're just out living our
lives part of the neighborhood yes
exactly renee richly very nice to meet
you enjoy doing the character and thank
you for bringing awareness to this thank
you so many survivors i'm sure are
thanking you as well